this is the curse of a general purpose
robot that they're not perfect at any
one thing but they might be able to do a
wide variety of things and and that is
that is the goal at the end of the day
you know I think we all want to build
general purpose robots that can be used
for lots of different activities
but it's hard and
um and the wisdom in in building
successful robots up until this point
have been go build a robot for a
specific task and it'll do it very well
and as long as you control that
environment it'll operate perfectly but
but robots need to be able to deal with
uncertainty if they're going to be
useful to us in the future
they need to be able to deal with
unexpected uh situations and that's sort
of the goal of a general purpose or
multi-purpose robot
and that's just darn hard and so some of
you know there's these curious little
failures like I remember one of the a
robot you know the first the first time
you start to try to push on the world
with a robot you you forget that the
world pushes back and and will push you
over if you're not ready for it and the
robot you know reached to grab the door
handle I think it missed the grasp of
the door handle was expecting that its
hand was on the door handle and so when
it tried to turn the knob it just threw
itself over it didn't realize oh I had
missed the door handle I didn't have I
didn't I was expecting a force back from
the door it wasn't there and then I lost
my balance so these little simple things
that you and I would take totally for
granted and deal with the robots don't
know how to deal with yet and so you
have to start to deal with all of those
uh circumstances well I think a lot of
us experience this in uh even when sober
but drunk too uh sort of you pick up a
thing and expect it to be
what is it heavy and it turns out to be
light yeah oh yeah and then so the same
and I'm sure if your depth perception
for whatever reason is screwed up if
you're if you're drunk or some other
reason and then you think you're putting
your hand on the table and you miss it I
mean it's the same kind of situation
yeah but
there's why you need to be able to
predict forward just a little bit and so
that's where this model predictive
control stuff comes in predict forward
what you think is going to happen
and then if and if that does happen
you're in good shape if something else
happens you better start predicting
again so if we like re-re-uh regenerate
a plan yeah when you don't I mean that
um that also requires a very uh fast
feedback loop of updating
what your prediction how it matches to
the actual real world
yeah those things have to run pretty
quickly what's the challenge of running
things pretty quickly a thousand Hertz
of acting and sensing quickly you know
there's a few different layers of that
you you want at the lowest level you
like to run things typically at around a
thousand Hertz which means that you know
at each joint of the robot you're
measuring position or force and then
trying to control your actuator whether
it's a hydraulic or electric motor
trying to control the force coming out
of that actuator and you want to do that
really fast
something like a thousand Hertz and that
means you can't have too much
calculation going on at that joint
um but that's pretty manageable these
days and it's fairly common
and then there's another layer that
you're probably calculating you know
maybe at 100 Hertz maybe 10 times slower
which is now starting to look at the
overall body motion and thinking about
the the larger physics of of the uh of
the robot
um and then there's yet another loop
that's probably happening a little bit
slower which is where you start to bring
you know your perception and your vision
and things like that and so you need to
run all of these Loops sort of
simultaneously you do have to manage
your your computer time so that you can
squeeze in all the calculations you need
in real time in a very consistent way
and the amount of calculation we can do
is increasing as computers get better
which means we can start to do more
sophisticated calculations I can have a
more complex model
doing my forward prediction
and and that might allow me to do even
better predictions as I as I get better
and better and and it used to be again
we had
you know 10 years ago
we had to have pretty simple models
that we were running you know at those
fast rates because the computers weren't
as capable about calculating forward
with a sophisticated model but as as
computation gets better we can we can do
more of that